we don't want people making that
dangerous Journey all we've really had
from the government though is the
announcement of a policy that doesn't
work then the reannouncement of the same
policy essentially and it often feels I
think like Groundhog Day and uh
meanwhile that's costing a fortune for
the taxpayer there's there's this
growing sense of frustration I mean I'm
at Hinckley Point C here today fantastic
project it's behind schedule and there's
a frustration here that there's no real
plan whether it's small boats or nuclear
from the government and that dither and
delay is holding our country back so
there's a pattern of behavior here and
it's it's no plan for this government a
dithering delay and that is holding us
back one thing the government has done
is made a deal for instance without
being here that they can send back
people who are not entitled company
hundreds have gone what do you see about
that that's a progress isn't it look a
deal with Albania it's a course progress
but we need many more returns agreements
because at the moment the government's
baked in a problem which is because they
haven't got returned agreements with
other countries because they're not
tackling this Upstream with cross-border
criminal activity being absolutely dealt
with and because they're not processing
the claims quickly enough they're
building an ever-growing problem and
there's this General sense now I think
that 13 years of holding our country
back dithering delay and not delivering
you know when we've got so much to offer
in this country